hot breath you say in your book that you
say in your book that
particular makes it universal makes it
universe
and that's how you've been able to
entertain so many different diverse
audiences
so what do you what is that particular
well that particular is just being able
to understand
the nature of things and being able to
convey that
to a group of people okay like
you know for instance you know
we've all seen a dog right
most people by that time by the time
they're at the club they've seen a dog
you know but do they know a difference
between a dog that bites or not
okay this is comedy okay right
because i'm showing you the particulars
right
so i'll give you my experience
on a dog that bites and a dog that does
that
so i'll give you my take all right i
think that a dog that
doesn't bite is the one that acts like
it bites
okay because this guy has got it's in
its bark
so the dog that doesn't bite gotta give
you more bark
to be convinced that he's a biter
so usually a dog that bites
hey
you know okay that is a dog that looks
like it bites
okay all right you can actually you can
see
you see how much is going into the bark
you see you see
ha ha ha ha
he's trying to convince me i can even
break his pattern by just kind of going
come over here you can break the pattern
get to it
so it's showing the audience as opposed
to telling them also
also helps right now i'll tell you about
a dog that does bite
a dog that does bite doesn't have to
bark
it knows it bites you have to find out
usually a dog that bites doesn't bark at
all because he doesn't want to bite you
because he know he can't help it and you
know he'll most likely get hurt
if he bites the hell out of you so he'll
try to kind of warn you as you walk over
i'll bite you i actually a dog that
bites kind of talks
kind of tries to let you know hey man
you're about to get
bitten so as i walk up on a dark advice
he doesn't bark he more kind of talks
[Music]
he's even trying to tell you okay
a doctor bites doesn't even look at you
he looks out the way
okay cause he's hoping you don't come
over
he might look for a second to see if
he's gonna bite your ass
okay steve stand up
i showed you something essential
something that everybody knows about a
dog and took you into a
intricate similarity
that everyone knows maybe not
intellectually but innately
and instinctually you see stand-up is
more than it did more than it actually
looks like
it looks like you can get up there hey
man you know my cousin i was walking
down the street one day
it's not really that there's a there's
so many dimensions of it
you know but another one of the
dimensions is set up
see i gave you setup